nous recevons maintenant l'invité de
paris direct
bonjour auguste cola bonjour merci de
venir sur notre plateau vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des questions de
défense romancier dans le livre la
flotte fantôme avec pizza beaulieu
singer vous imaginiez une troisième
guerre mondiale avec la chine comme
principal protagoniste la chine qui
avait un avantage certain sur le plan
technologique cette fois vous revenez
avec un autre livre dans le même genre
cela s'appelle techno thriller vous
allez nous dire ce que c'est le livre
s'appelle contrôle l'air de
l'intelligence artificielle et de
l'hyper surveillance a déjà commencé en
deux mots l'histoire
c'est une histoire de notre avenir avec
l'intelligence artificielle et robotique
c'est une histoire à une ingénieure plus
proche que la plupart des gens se
rendent compte
alors ces événements qui vient d'arriver
durant la dizaine d'années entre
aujourd'hui à 2022
[Musique]
sa rivale en 2030 des années 2030 alors
y'a pas que le change même sur les
niveaux technologiques mais aussi
politiques économiques et sociales alors
nous sommes aux états unis dans une
vingtaine d'années environ et le pays
est au bord de l'effondrement politique
économique il est menacé par un complot
pour déjouer ce complot il y à une agent
du fbi qui s'appelle laraque qui gagnent
et elle est aidée dans son travail par
un robot alors le robot s'appelle tams
et
tactical autonome os mobile mobility
système
exactement et ce que vous dites c'est
que tout cela est très vraisemblable et
existe même déjà dans la vraie vie tout
à fait les technologies les idées en
fait
contrôles sont tus en réalité où on voit
de belles à mon plus proche alors il ya
des notes dans sept livres alors que les
faits sont donnés aux lectures pour
eux-mêmes décidé c'est la vérité ou
c'est une possibilité une avenir plus
proche comme ça hyper surveillance le
robot est l'agent du fbi à y font équipe
les humains ont été remplacés par des
robots les humains salariés ont été
remplacés par des robots dans ce monde
que vous que vous imaginez et
l'intelligence artificielle pour le
pouvoir c'est ce qu'il faut comprendre
dans ce que vous nous expliquer dans
contrôles ont donné des grandes un
problème de cet avenir et que adaptation
de
irobo tisme ça va sûrement remplacé des
bruits des jobs et les gens qui ont peut
faire quoi après alors il ya des
questions aujourd'hui de betty king
comme ça c'est quoi le rôle de l'état
mais aussi pour chaque personne pour la
société c'était question presque
existentielle de leur identité parce
qu'aujourd'hui notre travail en fait
c'est vraiment notre entité mais 111 cet
aspect de société ça freine beaucoup
plus dur pour
être content et ça aussi ensuite par
avon
ça ça donne des conflit social
économique et même comme de terrorisme
on est dans l'intelligence artificielle
donc on est dans le monde gigantesque
que de la donner du big data comme on
dit en anglais et le livre renvoie à ce
que vous considérez comme étant une
nouvelle révolution industrielle qu'est
ce que c'est que cette nouvelle
révolution industrielle
avec cette
nouvelle vague de 2 d'état des
calculateurs performante avec l'ia et d
autres techniques il ya des possibilités
à quai no milk très profonde pour
améliorer la société ah ça c'est mon
côté optimiste mais un camp d' je pense
aussi d autres problèmes que ces
avancements
amené à la société comme chômage comme
l'extrême droite qui va être
incité par les algorithmes part de
sochaux médias et tout ça ça ça va être
très difficile pour la politique en fait
alors est ce que on ne nous on a
conscience de ce qui est en train de se
passer non je crois que
les sociétés dans l'ouest même france
mais aux états unis sont allés gens à se
rendre compact 7 ces changements viande
vient d'arriver plus tôt que là tout
l'art des expertes
pas configuré pour en revenir au coeur
de contrôle il y a auguste paul cette
collaboration si l'on peut dire entre
tams et
lara qui gagnent vous parlez de symbiose
quasiment entre l'homme et la machine
alors que naturellement on aurait
tendance à se méfier de la machine oui
la symbiose entre l'humain et la machine
est super important quand m en contrôle
même pour notre société chaque jour on
se lève on a regardé potable tue ça on a
commencé à faire qu'on fait sept procès
d'intégration pas pas exactement à haut
niveau de ducros en physique mais
surtout monde
la relation âge quotidien entre notre
technologie qui sont plus en plus
effectif un parle ya un sens vient
d'arriver déjà même pour des gens qui
travaillent dans la police et sécurité
c'est sûr que
l'intégration entre machines d'individus
ça va accélérer
durant une dizaine d ans qui vient tous
pensent que des déficits us avons
aventures du plus sérieux technologies
efficaces technologie effective parce
que réel technologie aussi intrusive qui
pose des problèmes de de liberté
individuelle de démocratie est ce que
pour en revenir à la question que je
vous pose est à l'heure est ce que nos
sociétés ont conscience des problèmes
d'ordre politique et de démocratie que
pose par exemple intelligence
artificielle
willaya s'est pas vraiment pas un grand
partie du discours politique dans les
dom à caen 6 mai au fond être vraiment
au centre de ces questions si on fait
les politiques aujourd'hui en 2022 sens
considérerait implication de ria a
sûrement ça ça va être
à intérêts de la sarthe a en fait une
truc à l'ancien dans une nature de
quelques années votre livre est truffé
de notes de bas de page vous en avez
touché un mot tout à l'heure elles sont
détaillées avec mille et une nuits
référence est-ce que l'auguste cool
c'était important d'apporter disons une
caution scientifique technique aux eaux
situation que vous décrivez oui quand on
ce site l'imagination avec les romains
des livres comme ghost le fantôme et
contrôle il faut être aussi à être
crédible avec les lacs turc transparente
avec un mât cherché à des notes et tout
ça alors là de l'utilisation dans une
techno thriller avec des notes s'est il
pas beaucoup d'aidé en turquie il faut
une bonne forme est due à la fin ça fait
deux thèses exactement c'est sam
académique ouais c'est ça et mais c'est
une hacking en fait d'une méthode parce
que nous croyons vraiment que les
l'acteur veut ça chez tous les
même chose que nous comme comme on a
créé c'est à venir quand on fait du
rétablissement du monde qui n'existe pas
encore et ses fameuses notes en bas de
pages nous faut nous souvenir enfin ceux
qui vous connaissent que vous êtes
chercheur auguste cole vous prononcer
des conférences auxquelles participent
des acteurs si j'ai bien compris un du
secteur privé des universités mais aussi
des cadres du gouvernement américain et
de leurs alliés vous dirigez aussi à
l'institut pour la paix d'oslo une
équipe spécialisée dans les armements de
guerre qui s'appuie sur l'intelligence
artificielle
en quoi consiste votre travail
c'est une bonne question à abidjan ce
que je crois pas mal même quand ce
qu'est ce que je fais ah non mais
sérieusement je suis un petit peu
chercheurs mais qui utilise les
histoires l'affection des romans et tout
ça comme une technique assez assez
précis en fait pour mieux comprendre qui
vient d'arriver avec la guerre future
des conflits futurs c'est tout à fait
différent que les modes tour des finales
en fait qui est white pearl
alors pointé tout ça je trouve bien que
les histoires a même comment comme comme
toi-même des projets les plus petits à
on peut trouver à des des plus grandes à
d'éprouvantes
hideaki que les gens vont pas vraiment
discuter mais l'histoire c'est que plus
facile pour le faire est vu sous cet
angle que vous inspire la guerre en
ukraine à l'actuel à laquelle nous
assistons en ce moment à
l'ukraine c'était très surprenant pour
moi à la limite est entre les opca pour
les réponses militaires j'avais beaucoup
peur avant dérives du confié qu'il n'y
avait pas de cohérence des politiques
entre eux
ayant pignon union européenne on est
allé ce dernier kate hudson aurait
humilié mais ça marchait très bien est
ce que l'intelligence artificielle
l'hyper surveillance peuvent être
utilisés pour promouvoir la paix
ça c'est une très bonne idée et je crois
que il ya déjà des opportunités pour
contrer la solution résolution du
conflit
avec lui pour utiliser la connexion
entre les gens oui c'est des gens
pouvaient se développaient de à mieux
comprendre les positions des autres on
voit bien que yaël adam réalité
augmentée une voiture elle vraiment
les opportunités très bien comprendre la
position de quelqu'un d'autre qui est
peut-être sur leurs deux côtés du
conflit et a donc à faire la promotion
de la paix oui c'est chaud optimiste
j'ai pas de dieu merci je viens je viens
de dire aussi qu'on fait des conflits et
ça va plus du tout dangereux en fait à
cause de robert belliot à tout ça merci
beaucoup augusto cold est revenu jusqu'à
nos co auteur avec peter de beaulieu
singer de contrôle l'air de
l'intelligence artificielle et de
l'hyper surveillance a déjà là merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur notre plateau
s'est invitée de paris direct les
formations internationales continuent
sur nos chaînes merci de rester sur
france 24